>> Sean: IT'S OVER.
BUT THE DEEP STATE IS NOT DONE
TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE WEEKEND.
DISGRACED FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY RIPPED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BILL BARR SAYING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS ECHOING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THAT'S A JOKE COMING FROM HIM.
MEANWHILE, A BOSTON HERALD
COLUMNIST POINTS OUT JAMES COMEY
HAS BEEN A CENTRAL FIGURE IN THE
BIGGEST CONSPIRACY THEORY IN
MODERN TIMES, MAINLY THE RUSSIA
HOAX.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOU KNOW, I READ STUFF.
AND I ONCE READ THE NUNEZ
REPORT.
TOOK THE TIME TO READ.
I READ THE GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO.
YOU MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH THAT
ONE.
AND IT SAID THAT THE BULK OF
INFORMATION -- THE BULK OF THE
INFORMATION IN THE FISA
APPLICATION IN OCTOBER OF 2016
THAT LED TO THE SPYING OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THEM THE TRUMP
TRANSITION TEAM, THEN THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY WAS THE HILLARY PHONY
UNVERIFIABLE RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
AND JAMES COMEY SIGNED IT.
AND IN JANUARY OF 2017, TOLD
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP IN TRUMP
TOWER, PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP,
OH, THAT IT'S SALACIOUS BUT NOT
VERIFIED.
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT HE SAID TO
THE FISA COURT.
THAT WOULD SOUND LIKE THE CRIME
WAS PERPETRATED ON THE COURT BY
JAMES COMEY TO ME.
BUT WHAT DO I KNOW?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT A THEORY.
WE KNOW THAT COMEY TOLD THE
PRESIDENT IN A PRIVATE MEETING
THAT I WANT YOU TO KNOW ABOUT
THE DOSSIER.
IT'S UNVERIFIED.
IT'S SALACIOUS.
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
IT'S THE SAME DOCUMENT GIVEN TO
THE COURT BEGINNING IN OCTOBER
WHERE THEY SAID UNDER OATH IT
WAS CREDIBLE AND RELIABLE TO GET
A WARRANT AGAINST AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
THOSE TWO THINGS DON'T ADD UP.
THAT'S NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THOSE ARE FACTS THAT NEED TO BE
RECONCILED.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE WHAT THEY
DID TO ATTORNEY JOHN DOWD JUST
DEFENDING HIMSELF.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF MUELLER LAST
WEEK, 9 1/2 MINUTES, EVERYTHING
HE SAID CONTRADICTED WHAT HE
PREVIOUSLY SAID ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF WHETHER OR NOT DOJ POLICIES
ALLOWS THE CONSIDERATION OF AN
INDICTMENT OF A SITTING
PRESIDENT AND THAT THAT WAS A
FACTOR.
BUT HE SAID JUST THE OPPOSITE TO
FIVE OTHER PEOPLE ON SEVEN OTHER
OCCASIONS.
>> SO, THIS IS IMPORTANT.
WHEN HE MET WITH BARR PERSONALLY
MONTHS BEFORE -- WEEKS BEFORE
THE REPORT WAS GIVEN OUT, HE
TOLD BARR, I CAN'T DECIDE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION, I'M GOING TO LET
YOU DO IT.
BUT I THE ID NOT MAKE MY
DECISION BASED ON DOJ POLICY.
YOU CAN'T INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
I THINK THE COMPLICATION OF THE
FACTS AND THE LAW, WE'LL TURN IT
OVER TO YOU.
HE NEVER MENTIONED IT TO THE
NEWS CONFERENCE.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
HERE'S WHAT HE DID IN THE
400-SOMETHING PAGE REPORT.
NO COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS.
HE DECIDED NOT TO BRING THE CASE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT BASED ON
OBSTRUCTION.
TO ME, CASE CLOSED.
LET'S LOOK AT COMEY AND McCABE,
STRUCK, PAGE, ALL OF THESE OTHER
PEOPLE AND SEE HOW WE GOT INTO
THIS MESS TO BEGIN WITH.
>> Sean: SENATOR, WE NOW LEARN
THAT ALL OF THIS SPECIAL
TREATMENT AND CONSIDERATION WAS
GIVEN TO HILLARY CLINTON.
YOU KNOW?
NO RECORDINGS, NO 302s.
YOU ALLOW OTHER PEOPLE TO SIT IN
ON AN FBI -- SUPPOSEDLY, AN
INTERROGATION INVESTIGATION
UNPRECEDENTED.
THEN YOU HAVE STRUCK AND PAGE
IMPLICATING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS HAVING THE FIX IN THE WHOLE
TIME.
THE SAME ONE THAT MET WITH BILL
CLINTON ON THE TARMAC FOR 45
MINUTES TO TALK ABOUT GRAND KIDS
ONLY.
AND WE KNOW THAT SHE VIOLATED
THE ESPIONAGE ACT BECAUSE JAMES
COMEY TOLD US SO.
THEN WE HAVE THE INTENTION --
THE ABIDES LYING THEISH THE
INTENTION OF DESTROYING THE
EVIDENCE THAT WAS SUBPOENAED IN
E-MAILS.
HOW DO WE SAY WE HAVE EQUAL
JUSTICE IN THIS COUNTRY?
AND EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS IF SHE GETS AWAY WITH THAT.
>> I THINK THE DECISION NOT TO
PROSECUTE HER WAS MOST LIKELY
NOT SPLI
NOT --LI
NOT -- LIKELY POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
TAKING A HAMMER TO TWO PHONES,
THAT'S EVIDENCE.
CLAIMING A BLEACH SO YOU CAN'T
GET THE E-MAILS, CLASSIC
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
COMPROMISE
COMPROMIING INFORMATION, SHE
DID THAT.
IF YOU WANT HER TO WIN, YOU
CAN'T PROSECUTE HER.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE A BIG SAY IN
THIS, SENATOR.
BECAUSE YOU HAPPEN TO BE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE POWERFUL
COMMITTEE THAT WILL LOOK INTO
THIS.
BUT, WE NOW ARE EXPECTING THE
HOROWITZ REPORT ON FISA ABUSE.
WE'LL HEAR SOMETHING ABOUT THE
ASPECT OF THE LEAKING ASPECT OF
ALL OF THIS.
MR. DORN WHO WANTED TO INTERVIEW
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, COULD BE A
GOOD FIRST STEP.
MAYBE OUR FRIENDS THE BRITISH
COULD EXTRADITE HIM.
THAT WOULD BE NICE.
AND THEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HIMSELF ANSWERED YOUR QUESTIONS,
IS MUELLER DEAD, YES?
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HILLARY INVESTIGATION?
YES, ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
FISA ABUSE?
INTEL ABUSE?
YES, WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN IN YOUR
VIEW GOING FROM HERE?
>> SO HOROWITZ WILL ISSUE HIS
REPORT ABOUT THE FISA WARRANT
PROCESS.
I WILL TAKE THAT REPORT AND SEE
IF WE NEED TO CHANGE OUR LAWS TO
MAKE SURE IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
DURHAM IS GOING TO LOOK AT ALL
OF THE CAST OF CHARACTERS TO SEE
IF THEY BROKE THE LAW.
AND BARR IS GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DOJ IS REFORMED SO IT'S
NEVER ABUSED IN THIS WAY IN THE
FUTURE.
MY JOB IS TO HAVE OVERSIGHT TO
CHANGE THE LAWS TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY FROM ABUSE IN THE
COUNTRY.
DURHAM IS LOOKING AT CRIMINALITY
AND BARR IS SITTING ON TOP OF
ALL OF THAT.
WE'LL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT
FOR THE GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU CAN'T
HAVE PEOPLE ENFORCING THE LAW
TAKING IT INTO THEIR OWN HANDS
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
>> ALL YOUR TRAVEL, I KNOW
YOU'RE DOING GREAT THINGS FOR
THE COUNTRY ON NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: BUT YOU'RE TAKING AWAY
FROM THE AUDIENCE HEARING
DIRECTLY FROM YOU WHEN YOU GO
AWAY FOR A WEEK.
I'M JUST SAYING.
>> CAN I SAY ONE THING ABOUT THE
BORDER?
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RIGHT TO DO
WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO STOP
THE DISASTER AT THE BORDER.
IT'S NOT A CRISIS.
IT'S A COMPLETE DISASTER.
AND MEXICO CAN DO BETTER.
THEY SHOULD DO BETTER.
AND I SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT IN
ANYWAY POSSIBLE TO GET MEXICO TO
DO BETTER AND I'M GOING TO HAVE
A VOTE ON MY BILL TO CLOSE THE